that was five years ago yesterday that
we first came on the air here in the
studio in El Segundo California and our
first in-studio guest that day is our
latest here on the Rich Eisen show the
man who is bringing us El Camino a
Breaking Bad movie on Netflix starting
to stream on Friday October 11th the man
who wrote and produced and directed this
film and the creator of Breaking Bad
Vince Gilligan back here on the show
great to see you Vince
crazy rich and it didn't awesome how I
timed it out so perfectly the premiere
is literally tonight yes and you know
what I I appreciate you waited for a
fifth anniversary this show to go ahead
and make Breaking Bad continue on
because that would have been a really
nice round number because I didn't want
to wait them you didn't want to wait
that long time well it's amazing we were
we came in what to work about a month
ago
six weeks ago yeah and then we were like
did you know there was a break yeah
we're like no idea how long was this in
the works it was in the works probably
about
in earnest probably about a year and a
half and and we did a real good job of
keeping it keeping it under oh did you
do that how did you keep it under oh you
know I have excellent producers they
figured out how to for instance you know
we were shooting an Albuquerque we had
we had cover stories that our producers
would make up they'd say you know I wish
there's a TV commercial being shot or
you know this or that or but it's just
amazing logistical achievement to keep
it secret and shooting an Albuquerque
helps to shooting in Los Angeles or New
York or something it's harder to keep
things under wrap under wraps but the
folks in Albuquerque are just kind of
cool and kind of chill and they they
they kind of it the folks who did know
about it and helped us keep the secret
and I appreciate that very much
well I mean it's it's fascinating that
you had the RV out there to write the
famed RV was that on the road there and
for the shoot at all they're like
something must be up if the RVs yeah you
know what you know that was sort of what
I was referring to you're exactly right
with there was one moment that the RV
happened to be at a certain location and
our it was actually one of our pas had
the idea to say you know what listen
we're gonna tell everybody that it's
that we're shooting a commercial for the
for the local Breaking Bad tour in which
you ride around in that barrier a cover
story and they handed up brochures for
the tour company that we were not
affiliated with the tour company but the
guy that runs it as a good guy and he
let us use his or visit cover as well he
has a cover exactly so it you know it
really impressive the feat of keeping us
safe now did you have to sneak the the
actors who are very famous like Aaron
Paul into town I mean you had to sneak
him in correct Aaron definitely snuck in
and out of town as much as possible and
yeah that but like I say also I just
want to give a shout out to the people
of Albuquerque who really a lot of them
probably knew something was up but they
just they just didn't make a giant
public thing of it now and cuz Bob
Odenkirk was the one who would let it
sneak right didn't you say something
like that
no actually Bob
Bob got a little more grief than he got
a lot more grief than he deserved on
that he didn't really let the cat out of
the bag in my in my estimation he was it
really he did he didn't do look I mean
and he is in phenomenal Aaron Paul is
phenomenal and so the question is now is
who's in this who can you tell us who is
in this because I mean you've got I
don't want to let it I want to make sure
I'm not letting anything out of the bag
here precious you know I want you to do
what you know whatever you need to do to
keep whatever you want in the bag before
Friday well Aaron Paul's in the movie
right had Charles Baker and Matt Jones
are in the movie skinny Pete and badger
okay and that's about all I can tell you
[Laughter]
okay I
my producers after having done that
amazing job of keeping a secret with
literally I Drive home from this taping
if I gave some away and they would just
beat me to death because you're so close
you're so close very close to use a
sports metaphor we run we're in the two
yard line you're on the two yard line
you stuck the landing but what can what
do have well what do you think what what
how much of the DNA of the show is in is
in this quiet quite a bit of the DNA DNA
of the show in its spirit and and in and
the embodied in the performance that
Aaron Paul gives which is just
absolutely tremendous he does such a
fantastic job in this movie he's a star
and I always knew he was a star I mean
you know after like day five or six of
the pilot I knew he was a star just like
I knew I already knew Bryan Cranston was
a star but this this young man they're
appalled I said this guy this guy's got
the goods well we played a clip earlier
events where you and your first time
here I hadn't heard that before that you
initially we're gonna kill Jesse
pinkman's character off in the first
season of Breaking Bad
and then the chemistry was just too damn
good and you're like we got to go back
to the drawing board on this character
exactly yeah so and man it wouldn't be a
movie now I know it's kind of iron
ironic in that in that regard as well
styling now when when you when you look
at Jesse pinkman's character and Aaron
Paul's character what do you think made
it work so well back in the day that you
decided let's go with this kid
I think he's got heart in real life and
both those actors Brian and Aaron can
play pretty much any any any character
they want they have that technical skill
that ability that talent but there's
something about heart you can you can
fake it but if you really have it to the
degree that Aaron Paul has it it just
comes out it leaks out because initially
you watch that first episode of Breaking
Bad Jesse Pinkman is kind of a little
creep and he's not necessarily that
likable nor was he intended to be in the
in the first episode of the pilot
episode but he became basically the
moral center of the whole entire TV show
because Aaron Paul has such Hart has
such goodness within him that it leaked
out whether any of us intended it to or
not and it and the show became a very
different show than it would have
because of who Aaron Paul fundamentally
is and that is to the good it became a
better show because of him Vince
Gilligan here on the Rich Eisen show the
writer and director and producer of El
Camino a Breaking Bad movie that is
going to stream on Netflix on Friday
October 11th true or false it starts
five minutes after the end of Breaking
Bad is that a true story this same day
well you know what I'll give you a
little spoiler no that is not true
that is not true it is not true okay
yeah all right I'll take that does it
tie up in a neat end is this the last
one of these I I think it's the last one
of these but then probably five years
our guys sit or whatever the last time I
was on the show I probably said that the
last breaking bad episode was the last
one of these two so I'm just apparently
a pathological liar
no you're not we call you a not we call
you a creator your your you've you've
got a writer's mentality and at some
point you just sit down baby or just it
does it just come over you saying you
know what I need to I've got this idea
to do this movie I just wanted to work
with her and Paul again really that was
that that coupled with the thought that
I kept having which is you know I
picture him getting away at the end of
the final episode of Breaking Bad right
how did he do that and that's that's
that's a lot of stuff that has to happen
to really get away or maybe he didn't
maybe he goes around the next corner and
he gets nailed by the cops I mean how
did what happened next and I wanted to
know what happened next and I wanted to
work with Aaron again it's kind of as
simple as that
alright I'm gonna ask a question that I
kind of don't want the answer to but I
want to know the answer to it is Walter
White dead you know what yeah I'm gonna
I'm gonna give you that one to rich
because I love you so much because it's
your fifth anniversary yes is dead yes
okay but is the actor who plays Walter
White somehow involved I'll take that as
an answer we can move on okay he's so
amazing Brian Christ is amazing did you
get to see him on Broadway when he was
doing I wanted to so bad I could not get
to New York I'm hoping somehow someway
that if he wants to do Network again I
couldn't see it in London couldn't see
it in New York he's was LBJ there - I'm
assuming talking about being in network
well it started by bandsaw yeah he was
great as LBJ he was great and in network
s I was lucky I saw the production in
London and in New York for Network for
network where he plays Howard Beale
plays Howard which I'm hoping he'll do
it in Los Angeles just one more time is
he gonna be there tonight at the at the
premiere I hope so yeah okay by the way
lots of people who are not in the movie
why would he go to the premiere exactly
Warren Buffett's gonna be at the
premiere and he is definitely not in the
mood again cuz you Vince Gilligan you
could go you can go in any direction you
want where you can have flashbacks you
can have moments of dreaming you could
do whatever you want to bring anybody
back to life in a dance sequence yeah
you could have a debt would be kind of
odd that would be very David Lynch of
you to do something like that
you know why is Warren Buffett gonna be
there because he's cool
we're Buffett is like one of the biggest
fans of Breaking Bad out there are you
serious for sure if it for real Warren
is is awesome and he visited the set in
her final season I was shot a little
video for his Berkshire Hathaway annual
shareholders meeting great and I think
it was 2013 and and we got to know him I
got to know him at that point and I've
been to his my girlfriend Holly and I've
been to his annual meeting every year
since in Omaha and it's awesome it's
like this amazing party and he's just
cool tell me the video for Berkshire
Hathaway it was they do a funny video
every year at the meeting and the
shareholders loved it and this one was
breaking bad related in that Walt and
Jesse are cooking in their RV cooking
meth know what I'm sorry that good back
cooking peanut brittle because Warren
and Berkshire Hathaway owns See's candy
and Warren Buffett shows up in the
Heisenberg Hat and says I want to buy
you out I'm cornering the market on
peanut brittle and I want to I want to
buy you out takeover and so warns in it
interacting with the Walt and Jesse were
in their cook suits in the middle of the
desert we shot it with the real RV and
the real props and all that and then at
the end of the that's I get like an
eight-minute video and then at the end
of it Charlie Munger is dressed like
Jesse Pinkman and he says brittle
[ __ ] look at Charlie Munger if you
don't know he's about I don't 93 94
years old smart as a whip one of the
richest men in hard yeah how long were
the Warren Buffett and when he I story I
heard his when he got the script he said
what and the hell does this mean what am
i what am I saying why do I have to
dress that
good game he was game he did it was the
brittle blue was the peanut brittle no
it was I think it was C's which is
you're trying to be on brand for the
company oh yeah stana there was no drug
references in this man to say he's very
clean very very g-rated for the family
Vince Gilligan here on the Rich Eisen
showed the most so some of the other
people that came up to you said man I
love Breaking Bad that was really
surprising to you like obviously out of
the Warren Buffett world that you
couldn't believe was okay you know stuff
that I'm thrown out there I was I was
eating lunch at one point with my with
my agent and this gentleman comes up and
stands next to table says I'm sorry I
never do this I'm a fan of your show and
I look up and it's friggin Russell okay
and I was just like and I was stuck I
was stuck
somehow it was like a little I don't
know how would the arrangement was I'd
litters like this with the my confirm
ahead couldn't stand up right to shake
his hand and I was just like and I was
so blown away Kurt Russell who's like
the coolest guy who ever lived
and him coming up and saying that it
just to this day I'm thinking did I
dream that but that actually happened
and then he was gone it was like I shook
his hand and then he was like and it was
saying that was that was a true
highlight that's cool I that was that
was tremendously oh you're such a nice
guy Vince because you could pretty much
work with whoever the hell you want in
this town you could pretty much like hey
I've got this idea and then that person
would say okay I'm in I mean cuz of what
you've proven your track record is just
amazing you are welcome no serious
letter start thinking of some ideas that
well you're better stop by riding the
Breaking Bad gravy train into the ground
you're I mean and I can't wait to again
I can't wait to see this it's El Camino
a Breaking Bad movie so you think it's
possible that you're gonna do another
one of these cuz I mean look I know less
is more and I know that more isn't
sometimes more yeah but for fans of
Breaking Bad the fact that we're gonna
see it we've already gotten better call
Saul you know now we're gonna get a
continuation of Jesse's character yeah
that's true
is something else I I do not intend to
do anything further at this point I'm
not being I'm not
trying to be coy I just but then I
didn't intend to do anything further
after Breaking Bad I just sort of go
where your heart takes you but having
said that I feel like what I really
probably should do next to do something
completely different because you know
you you you it's it's a interesting
golden handcuffs that that some that
success gives you you you you want you
want that success to continue and the
safest way to you think to do that is to
keep keep in mind in that same vein of
or you know that the you know to keep
keep telling that same story but I
really figure I better I better do
something new next time around so better
call Saul returns when Vince Gilligan
when does that come back on Lindsay
early early 2020 I think round about
February and that's shot out that season
is shot out yeah that season is season
five just finished shooting a couple
weeks back and I was very lucky I got to
direct Episode eight okay out of our ten
episodes that show is in really
rock-solid hands it's been run by Peter
Gould I think was earlier before yeah
Peter and the writers doing a tremendous
job the show just gets better and better
without me which is that's a real nuts
nothing you have nothing to do with it
very little I mean I directed the one
episode that is kind of a director for
higher right they gave me the script and
I read it and I said this is awesome and
then I figured out how to as one does
figure out how to shoot it but I you
know I really they are running it and
okay come on great guns do do you or
they know how it's going in to better
call Saul the end of that is that doctor
I think Peter just like I'm being coy
with you Peter Scott accorded me says I
got some ideas come on he doesn't share
with you
come on no he he he does okay he's but
they're still percolating too so
sometimes you don't want to you don't
want to give too much away to others
because it kind of kind of messes things
up in your own head sure okay and then
when it all is said and done with better
call Saul is there another character
that you'd want to parse out
give me one other characters from I mean
here's the thing I'd parse out all of
them they're all they're all tremendous
actors but the question is do you keep
do you keep going down out of the mine
and you know you know do you find a new
mind you didn't find a new patch of
ground to start digging and it's you
know what I'd love to do I'd love to
work with these actors in other things
sure a non-breaking Badnaam better call
so well Cranston has been on this show
and has said if you call him he will do
whatever you'd ask him to do my said
that I mean he has essentially said I'm
I'm I'm in because if you called so you
know who else is great and he's the best
there is it's Bryan Cranston Bob
Odenkirk is all good man he is amazing
so I guess I was gonna follow the house
as Bryan Cranston have you called Bryan
Cranston
have you called Braun did I call him to
invite him to the premiere along with
Warren Buffett who's not in the movie
okay yeah is Huell in the movie it's
Huell in the movie oh she still cuz last
we saw him he was just stuck in a hotel
room and we were wondering what happened
that's right Netflix by the way is doing
this awesome thing it flicks has been
fun to work with I have to say I've
really enjoyed working with those guys
and they are very enthusiastic and
they've got this thing I don't know when
it's gonna go live but it's Huell in the
hotel in the in the room in the
apartment waiting sitting and waiting
cuz you're right right Curtis people
have been asking for years whatever
happened to heal so they're doing this
promotion so yes who is involved in a
and it is so funny it's I think
literally have them sitting there for
hours and if you are disposed to do so
you can literally watch him for me it's
one of the best gifts ever of Huell
falling onto the bed of cash what is
before I let you go your favorite
breaking bad episode the one where
you're like if that's the one that's the
one that I'm most proud of acting
writing either you directed it or you
didn't which one is this hard to pick a
favor but you know because I would
imagine I'm not a father but it'd be
like picking a favorite child but I
guess that we had an episode called
Ozymandias which was one the third from
the father it's the last one and I
neither wrote nor directed it and it was
so amazing
written by Moira Wally Beckett who's an
excellent writer who does a show now
called called and which is her
adaptation of Anne of Green
Gables it's on Netflix it's tremendously
good and then Rian Johnson brilliant
director Brian Johnson who's got a movie
called knives out coming out in November
he directed it she wrote it they just
killed it it's a tremendous episode and
it was just fun to hang on the set and
watch them work and not have any
responsibilities I would just run around
behind the scenes taking pictures it was
one of my greatest memories on the set
and the may press hard you believe the
greatest episode way ever did it devs
the third to last one I mean I don't
want to what is your take on spoiler
alerts that people haven't seen Breaking
Bad I mean it's been years they've had
time but I don't want to I could go down
the road as to what that episode was
about
oh yeah the statute of limitations has
run out okay so the long that I mean
that was so much happened in the desert
it's when it you know the you know what
really hit the fan yeah so many of the
plot lines and it was brilliantly acted
and directed the whole business and I'm
just so honored Vince that I can call
you a friend
email you and just basically say hey how
about you come back in I'm so glad I
found Boyd you didn't in an airport
about eight years you know what I should
have told that story because and by the
way come everyone in this in lax because
he's rich is not going to say this he
comes over to me and he says I just I
love Breaking Bad and and meanwhile the
guy at the Southwest gate or Delta or
where we're on that we're on a six yard
line and whoa this guy is so desperately
tap-dancing away on the mic to get rich
to even look at him and everyone and I'm
so tuned out everyone I look over
everyone staring over this way and every
single one I'm looking at rich and the
guy is freaking out so much he's such a
fan dude and then meanwhile you're being
so nice to me my gosh and was that was
that that was the best time I ever spent
in LAX yeah Vince you're the best man
and I can't wait to see on Friday
the first thing I do when I'm gonna be
over in London Susie and I are gonna go
there where as soon as this thing drops
because it's internationally available
to we're gonna be all over it
day and date and Netflix has been great
I love them so watch it on Netflix but
if you can see it in a movie theater
here sure in the United States only in
the US
this thing is a movie it is meant to be
was shot on the area 65 it's got its got
the Atmos Dolby Atmos sound it's it's a
very vision it's gorgeous to look at not
because of me because of my DP Marshall
Adams it is a movie if you can see it in
a movie theater do by all means
it looks awesome then I hope certainly
next time you come back here we'll be
talking about an Oscar nomination I
would love it I deserve it you deserve a
fence Gilligan and check it out either
in a theater or on Netflix streaming
Friday October 11th that is El Camino a
Breaking Bad movie
thanks for coming congratulations and
five years I'm so proud to be back well
I'm appreciative of you being part of it
it was just awesome five years ago and
you were back with Peter Gould for
better call Saul and I can't wait for
that to return as well thanks for coming
on thanks so much that's Vince Gilligan
here and by the way I don't think our
researcher el0 who's a big Tampa Bay ray
fan wants you to leave because ever
since you came into our building the
racist I think he wants you to leave you
got a stay for more of the Rich Eisen
show tune - audience Channel 239 on
DirecTV for free on BR live or download
the Rich Eisen show app